le salon de l'automobile qui se tient
tous les deux ans à paris est un moment
important pour tous les constructeurs
comme pour les usagers d'ailleurs en
effet cette manifestation vous le savez
fait office de test sur la santé du
marché automobile français et
international ce matin la régie renault
doit souffler si j'ose dire puisque le
plan proposé par monsieur bernard
arnault le pdg de la régie a été
acceptée par les syndicats qui au
passage ont obtenu gain de cause sur
leurs revendications immédiates
concernant les congés mobiles le pouvoir
d'achat
renault qui profitent de ce salon pour
présenter la supercinq ce ne sera pas la
seule nouveauté de ce grand
rassemblement automobile jean claude
renaud la super 5 est le seul vrai
nouveau modèle français du salon et
renault la mise en bonne place en fait
les nouveautés sont plus dans des
versions différentes de modèles
existants que dans des modèles nouveau
mais bernard à nous expliquer aux
journalistes étrangers quand 86 toute la
gamme renault serait renouvelée avec
promet-il un retour du groupe à l'
équilibre financier
le pdg de la régie expliqué aussi qu'il
compte vendre en 87 600 mille voitures
aux américains dont cette alliance
décapotable réservé aux états unis c'est
dommage
autre fierté de renault la r25 v6 turbo
la reine qui s'attaque aux belles
allemandes 225 km heure système
antiblocage de roues en série n'est plus
de 180 mille francs dans sa version
limousine plus luxueuse elle atteint 215
milles francs à noter encore la régie
l'espace
elle a dit txeroki nouvelle venue sur le
marché français du côté de psa c'est
citroën qui affiche le plus de nouvelles
versions avec une surprise pour les
artisans deux utilitaires sur la base de
la vise à laisser 15e et d epuis la bx
19 j'étais là visages étaient cousines
de la 205 gti de peugeot et enfin le
fleuron la cx 25 gti turbo 220 km heure
près de 180 me rends chez peugeot outre
une 305 gtx la 205 s'apprête à avaler de
nouvelles parts du marché
averses avec ses versions 1 x en 3
portes
à noter qu'un constructeur français se
décide enfin équilibre à équiper ses
voitures d'un toit ouvrant
transparent et pour terminer voici les
cotes 2002 citroën un prototype
expérimental
celui là ne roulent pas mais la future
de chevaux qui sera peut-être prochain
salon en 86 pourrait bien lui ressemble
les constructeurs